Rubin: Thank you
for joining us today.
We're really, really excited
to present Honeycomb,
and, uh, and some new
features of Android
and also some really,
really interesting demos.
We have a couple of people
getting onstage with us.
We have a pretty good demo
of the Motorola Xoom tablet
running Honeycomb,
and Hugo is gonna present that,
who's our Director of PM.
And after that, Chris Yerga's
gonna get onstage
and talk about some of
the future functionality
and features
of Android Market.
And we have some really
exciting news there as well.
And just briefly, let me talk
a little bit about
how excited I am
about the momentum.
It's, uh, you know, Android
obviously,
you know, being
an open-source project,
we consider ourselves
the shepherd of it.
And as we shepherd it
through the industry,
we're seeing it just pop up
all over the place.
At CES,
when I walk the floor,
it was just amazing
and surprising
about all the different
variety of devices
that popped up
running Android.
Again, you know,
with open source,
you don't really know what
people are gonna do with it,
and, you know,
all the innovation
doesn't happen
in this building.
It happens all around us.
So there's a lot of
excitement,
and a lot of opportunity,
future opportunity,
for finding Android
in new places.
When you see Hugo's demo,
one of the things
you're gonna witness is
how Google's cloud services
tie together
all these different
applications
and all these different
companies
that are making devices
in all these different segments.
Again, it's the cloud that
makes the experience seamless.
You could literally lose
your laptop or lose your phone
or lose your tablet,
and all your data's safe
and secure in the cloud.
The next time you pick up
your new tablet,
it all comes back.
The cloud is also
the central point
at which all the applications
and services
share information.
So in the future,
you'll be able to see
a real seamless integration
between phones and tablets
and, you know, Google TV,
which is also based on Android.
And before I bring Hugo up,
the one thing I wanted
to mention is
I truly believe
the Android team,
the folks over in
building 44
with all the Android
statues out front,
I really, truly believe
they're the hardest working
team in mobile.
They sweat the details,
and they're there right now,
actually,
putting the finishing touches
on what we're
talking about today.
Uh, so I really, really would
appreciate it
if you mention them
when you talk about Android,
because they're the ones that
are actually creating it.
Okay, Hugo, come on up
and show off your stuff.
Barra:
Thanks, man.
Thank you, Andy,
and good morning
and welcome, everyone.
From the very beginning,
the Android project,
as Andy said,
has been committed
to open development.
And one of the most critical
aspects of open development
is creating an ecosystem
platform
that enables developers
to iterate
and innovate
as quickly as possible.
So our approach with Android
has been to equip developers
with the best possible
tool kit that we can build
and then simply
get out of their way.
So with Honeycomb,
we're enabling this style
of rapid, agile development
that the internet has been
used to for so many years
on this new generation of
tablet-sized mobile computers.
So today I'm gonna show you
some of the new features
of this platform
that we've designed
specifically keeping in mind
the creation of amazing apps
that are optimized
for tablet-sized computers.
So let me start by giving you
an overview of Honeycomb.
And first what you'll see
is that
we've revamped
how you navigate
in a device with a larger
screen like this.
So if you look at the bottom
left of the screen,
you'll see that there's
a back button,
there's a home button,
and there's also a new button
that's dedicated
to multitasking.
So when I tap that,
you'll see visual previews
for some of the applications
that I was using recently,
and the state that they're in,
so it's actually really easy
to switch back and forth.
Over here on the bottom right,
you'll see the notifications
and systems status area,
which I'll talk about
in just a little bit.
And the rest of the screen
is dedicated entirely
to applications.
And the home screen is actually
a really important part
of our developers' story.
It's not just a warehouse
full of apps.
It's an application
development platform in itself,
and I'll talk
a little bit about that.
For example,
widgets, as we call them--
and by the way,
the widget system
is the same that's been hugely
popular in Android phones--
can now be backed by
collections of data.
And these collections of data
can be visualized
in some interesting ways.
So right here, you're seeing
my Gmail inbox
that I can scroll through.
You also see my calendar.
I can even scroll
through them together,
and it's just really easy
with multi-touch support.
If I move over here
to this home screen,
I have a grid widget
for my bookmarks.
And if I scroll once again,
I have what we call
a stack widget
that allows me to flick through
different things,
for example,
Major League Baseball highlights
or my books over here
or some YouTube videos
that are popular today.
And I can even sort of
do this together
and actually have
a lot of fun with it.
So there you go.
So these widgets
are sort of reusable
pre-built components
that developers can use
to bubble up important
information to the home screen.
From a user's perspective,
what really matters is
despite all of the clever
computer science that we have
to enable the smooth experience
that you just saw,
it's really just about
quick and easy access
to important information.
Now, another thing
that we've redesigned
on Android, on Honeycomb,
is the notification system.
And as you'll see, notifications
are completely nonintrusive.
They don't get in your way
just like on phones.
But now they contain
more information,
so in this particular case,
my friend Anand
is IMing me,
and you can see his picture
in the notification.
And you can ignore it, or
you can action it if you want.
What we've done
is we've built--
Maybe I should tell him
to stop.
What we've done is
we've built some templates
that actually allow
developers to create
these richer, more advanced
kind of notifications.
And I'll show you
a few of those.
Probably my favorite example
is what I'm gonna show you now.
There's a headphone
notification at the bottom here.
I was listening to some music
before getting onstage,
and while the music app
is active in the background,
I get this notification
that if I click on
will allow me to play, pause,
or go to the next track,
for example, like this.
[hip-hop plays]
And I can just pause that.
Now, if I tap on
the notifications area
anywhere here
on the bottom right,
I'll be able to dismiss
some of these notifications
if I don't need them anymore.
We call this a line item veto.
And while I'm in
the neighborhood,
let me talk about the quick
settings panel right here.
This gives me quick access
to important things
like airplane mode, WiFi,
and so on and so forth.
Just right there
in one place.
So now I want to show you
some of the new
application patterns
that we've created as part
of the Honeycomb UI framework.
But before I do that,
let me just point out the fact
that we've spent
a significant amount of effort
making sure that existing
Android applications
run really well on tablets.
In fact, an app
that's been designed
with our recommended
development guidelines
is going to work
without any modifications
and run really well
on Android,
and I want to show you
an example,
in fact, one of my
all-time favorite games,
which is of course
Fruit Ninja.
So because I was
playing this earlier,
I'm gonna see that
it's actually showing up here
in my recents,
by touching
the multi-tasking button.
So I'm gonna go
into Fruit Ninja,
and I'll play this
for a little bit.
Now, this is a completely
unmodified version
of Fruit Ninja,
in fact what's available
in Android Market today.
And it was built
before Honeycomb even existed.
And it works amazingly well.
It even supports
multi-fingered,
multi-handed gestures
if you want.
You can probably also tell
that I am really good--
or getting really good
with this.
But I'll pause that
for a second.
So it works really well
even though it was built
before Honeycomb even existed,
as I said.
Now, of course,
we want to encourage
application developers
to built tablet-optimized
experiences
for the applications.
And to do that, we've added
a lot of really cool, new things
to they Honeycomb
application framework.
One of these things is what
we call an application fragment,
and I want to show you
what that is
inside of Gmail.
So let me open
Gmail over here.
So we're in landscape mode.
And in landscape mode,
you're gonna see two panes,
the left folder view
and then my Inbox on the right.
Now, watch what happens
when I click on a message,
when I tap on a message.
You see that
the left-most pane slid out
to make room for another pane,
the message, that then slides
into the same place.
and if I click on the Inbox,
you see that the side--
the left-most panel
or pane slides back in.
These panes are what we call
application fragments,
and a fragment is something
that a developer can use
to encapsulate specific
application functionality,
and then reuse that
throughout the application.
So, for example, if I flip
this tablet into portrait mode,
um, I may want,
and probably will want,
to recombine how these
fragments are laid out.
And, eventually,
fragments are gonna be useful
so that you can have completely
reusable functionality
between the phone and the tablet
version of your application.
So that's coming
in the future.
Another really cool action
is being able to pick up
and then drag a message,
for example, into a folder.
And this is something
that has been built
not as part of Gmail,
but part of
the application framework.
We have an incredibly
full-featured dragging manager
that allows you
to create and manage
sort of these
dragging interactions.
There's a lot more
coming there.
And then one last thing
that I wanted to show
is across the top here,
is the application bar.
The application bar
is another application pattern
that can be packaged
into a fragment,
and in this case,
it contains--
It's showing global actions,
so, like, I have Search,
I have Compose,
and a few other things.
But if I select
a few messages,
you'll see that
application bar now changes
to contain actions
that are specific
to the selected items.
In this case Archive,
Star, Label, et cetera.
So this is another example
of sort of really
modular developments
that we've built as part of the
Honeycomb application framework.
Go back to the home screen.
Now I want to talk a little bit
about performance.
Needless to say, we've spent
a tremendous amount of time
really optimizing performance
at every level on Honeycomb,
especially for
2D and 3D graphics.
So first, all of 2D drawing
that developers have been doing
with the existing framework
can now be
hardware accelerated.
And developers
can actually do that
literally by adding
just one line of code
to their existing application,
and then they can take advantage
of hardware acceleration.
We've also added a new animation
framework to Honeycomb,
to enable developers to add
transitions and overall polish
to their applications,
and you've seen
some of that stuff
already in the home screen.
I want to show,
in a really simple way,
how powerful this is.
So I'm gonna click on the top
button here on the right,
and that's gonna take me
into the home screen
customization UI.
And then I'm gonna tap on the
home button on the bottom left,
and then I'll do that
in rapid sequence,
and you can see
how amazingly powerful
this new animation
framework is.
Just incredibly
fluid and smooth.
We're also introducing
a brand new graphics engine
called Render Script.
Render Script is built
for high-performance
interactive 3D graphics,
and it enables
some amazing new things,
some of which I believe
you've already seen.
Let me show you one of the best
examples of this,
which is YouTube.
So I'm gonna go
to YouTube here,
and what you see
is this insanely beautiful
3D video wall
that I can use
to browse videos on YouTube,
and you can see how fluid
and awesome it is to play with.
This is built
using Render Script.
I'll go into our Books app,
and in the Books app,
you'll see a 3D carousel of
the books that I've purchased,
also built with Render Script.
And if I go
into a book here,
I've chosen "Unbroken."
Watch how incredibly smooth
the turning the page
flipping animation is,
even when you have pictures.
It's just really beautiful.
This is all built
using Render Script
technology as well.
Just for fun, I want to show
just a few more examples
of 3D applications
that we can build,
or that can be built
on Honeycomb.
We've spent
as much time as we could
optimizing performance
at every level.
Even doing things like
supporting
multi-processor cores,
or multi-core processors
at the kernel level
to make sure that everything
works super smoothly.
So let me take Maps
as an example.
So I'll go into Maps here.
And with this
new version of Maps,
as some of you may know,
we're adding dynamic
rendering technology
with three-dimensional
vector graphics,
and what that allows is
for me to do manipulations
of all sorts on a map.
So I can zoom. I can do some
rotations, for example.
I can tilt the map.
Uh, and If I go close,
I can even start
to see some buildings.
Look how beautiful it is
to look at the Embarcadero.
Just incredibly cool.
I will also show
our music application,
which is over over here.
And I'll go to, uh...
I'll go over here.
So look at this
incredibly smooth
sort of carousel
that allows me
to browse through my albums.
Also built
using the 3D constructs
that are part
of the application framework.
And one last and really fun
example is Google Body,
which is a new application
that I've heard some call
the Google Maps
of human anatomy.
And I can do here,
you know,
things that you would expect
from Maps,
like pan and zoom.
I can also turn on layers.
But in this case,
there are layers like muscles,
or maybe the circulatory system,
or skeleton,
and I can zoom in here.
And perhaps this is useful,
maybe,
to tell my doctor on the phone
that I've broken my clavicle.
Uh, or if my doctor
tells me that, uh,
maybe I've pulled
my infraspinatis,
I can actually
find out what that is.
Doesn't look that serious.
So, speaking of 3D graphics,
I wanted to invite
an expert over to the stage.
So please welcome
Thomas Williamson
from War Drum Studios
to show some of the amad--
amazing things that you can
build using 3-D graphics
on Honeycomb.
Thomas, come on up.
Williamson: Thank you, Hugo.
My name is Thomas Williamson.
I'm the CEO
of War Drum Studios.
We're a game developer based
out of Gainesville, Florida.
And we're recently,
uh, we've moved completely
over to mobile development
and next-generation game
development on Android.
So we have a few games
I want to show you.
The first game
is "Monster Madness."
That's the first tablet here.
Okay, so "Monster Madness"
is a South Peak Games title
that was a PS3 game.
And we've brought it
over to Android
using the same assets,
the same gameplay logic,
the same animations.
And you kind of get
a cinematic feel...
[rooster grunting]
[crash]
And so the game itself,
it's a hack-and-slash shooter.
Uh, you have up to two people,
so you can have Wi-Fi call up
with two different tablets.
Uh, fighting enemies coming
from all around you,
hundreds of particles.
You have explosions.
You have destructible
environments.
You're--
Blow up the barrel, Ben.
There goes. [laughs]
So you have a--
a lot of performance
and high definition context
with "Monster Madness."
And the game's gonna feature
five huge environments,
four difficulty levels,
vehicular combat,
the whole nine yards.
We're trying to throw
everything we can at the player,
and the high performance
of Android
and what Honeycomb provides
allows us to do that.
So let's move on
to the second tablet,
and I can show you...
"Great Battles Medieval."
So "Great Battles Medieval"
is, uh, "History Channel
Presents Great Battles..."
And it is a cooperative
development
between War Drum Studios
and Slitherine Software.
And so this title is basically
an educational strategy game
with massive battles.
And it's the first
title that we've done
that has 100% usage
of two cores on tablet, and--
Or, you know,
we're looking
to support the phones
as well.
The game itself
shows hundreds of units
animating, moving,
uniquely thinking.
All in a massive battle,
all on your phone,
all on mobile.
Just try to get a...
[men grunting]
So it really pushes
the tablets to the limit,
and you can look forward
to all of--
both of these titles
within the next month.
Thank you for your time.
[applause]
Barra: Thank you, Thomas.
That was--
that was absolutely stunning.
Um, finally, I'd like to talk
a little bit about
the new media capabilities
of the Honeycomb platform.
It's live multitasking here.
So, um, I want to show you
the new Camera app
that we've built,
because it has a completely
stunning new UI.
So, as you can see here
on the right,
uh, we have a really slick
new UI for--
to expose all of the controls
that you want
when you're taking
a picture.
So I can, you know, control
the flash, white balance,
and exposure settings,
color effect, et cetera.
Um, I can also flip to
the front camera if I want.
Uh, I'll go back
to the main camera
and I'll just take
a picture of you guys.
That's a little shaky
over there.
Um, so there you go,
and I can, of course,
also shoot a video and upload it
instantly to YouTube.
We think this is a really cool
new UI.
And, uh, hopefully,
you'll love it.
Uh, now Android
has also been
an amazing
communications platform.
And this device has
a front-facing camera,
which is really great
because Honeycomb
supports video chat.
So I want to show you
a little bit of video chat.
And what you won't
see here necessarily,
because the tablet is sort
of fixed in a stable position,
is that we've actually spent
a lot of time,
uh, building image
stabilization technology,
uh, as part of video chat
on Honeycomb,
both to make the experience
really smooth,
but also to save bandwidth,
recognizing that,
a lot of times,
users are gonna be
on cellular networks
with--with a device
like this.
And it works really,
really well.
Uh, to show you video chat,
I'm going to actually
contact my friend
Lady Killer.
Lady Killer is his nickname.
You probably already
know who it is.
And you certainly will know
as soon as we connect.
So let's see if we can
talk to Lady Killer here.
Uh, looks like he might not
be online.
Let me, uh,
let me go into Talk.
Maybe we'll try, uh,
logging out.
Oh, I'm not signed in.
There we go.
That would help.
So what I'll do here
from my home screen
is I'm gonna use a widget
that's called
a Contact shortcut,
which allows me
with a single click
to actually email or--
or start a video chat
with someone.
Um, it doesn't--
my friend Lady Killer
isn't showing
as online yet.
Um, so maybe we'll try that
in a little bit.
Uh, or perhaps I'll just chat
with my friend, uh,
Anand here.
Let me try that.
Lady Killer, where are you?
Hmm, still offline.
Well, let's just talk
to my friend Anand here
on video chat.
[phone line ringing]
Hey, Anand.
How are you, man?
Anand: Hey, what's up?
Barra: It's going pretty well.
Anand: Sorry I'm not
Lady Killer.
I'm not--I'm not bad
with the ladies, though.
[laughter]
Barra: I'm sure you're not.
Hope you're having
a good time, man, though.
So, uh, I'll see you
a little bit later, okay?
I just wanted to make sure
that everybody saw
the new video chat technology
that's part of Honeycomb.
And maybe Lady Killer will
show up in a little while.
Anand: Cool.
See you around.
Barra: Thanks, man.
Yeah, Lady Killer
still isn't there.
Well, um, of course,
there's probably no one
in the world
that knows how much video
is capable of changing things,
changing the world in itself,
than CNN.
So I'd like to invite
my colleague and friend,
uh, Louis Gump from CNN
to show an amazing
new application
that CNN has been building
using the Honeycomb platform.
Louis, come on up.
Gump: Thanks, Hugo.
Thank you, Hugo.
Make sure we're all set up here.
Okay,
good morning, everyone.
I'm Louis Gump, Vice President
of Mobile at CNN.
I'm here with Lila King
who heads up our iReport group.
We're really excited
to be here this morning
to talk a little bit
about a new application
we've been building.
We've been hard at work
on an Android app
for the tablet
and it will be launching
in the near future for free
in the Android market.
And we'd like to give you
a little sneak peek.
First of all, I'd like
to share a bit of context.
It's no secret that tablets
are becoming a force
in the marketplace
and are going to be something
we're watching
throughout the year.
And as part of this,
CNN has decided that mobile
is a core strategic priority.
As part of the strategy
of making sure
that we meet consumer needs
on mobile,
we want to make sure
that we're there
for Android users
around the world.
We've learned quite a bit
over time.
And what we're trying to do
is to take what we learn
and put it into a really
compact package
that goes where consumers are.
So if you take a look,
you can see what we refer
to as the broadsheet here.
It's a compilation
of content.
You can have as many
as 350 stories in one sheet.
However, if you want to dig down
into a more focused thing,
you can go into the left
fragment there,
and it goes back to what Hugo
was speaking to
in terms
of dividing up the screen.
And then you can pick
a category
or you can swipe from left
to right.
In addition to that,
when you find a story
you're interested in,
you can just go in,
look at the content,
and then keep on going.
And I have to tell you,
based on some
of the experiences
we're having in testing,
this is an incredibly
immersive experience.
Consumers love it and there's
a lot of time spent
in the application.
That's, in many respects,
the core of the apps
because it's so rich
and there's so much to it.
However, if you look at the top
in the action bar,
you will see both
an audio update
and also live video.
And the live video is something,
of course,
that goes to the core
of what CNN is all about.
Here you can see
a live stream.
We have live streaming video
both from the U.S.
and also internationally.
In this case,
it's some of our coverage
of the protests in Egypt.
So you can get a sense
of what's going on.
We cover both the top stories
and breaking news.
And we take advantage
of the HLS capabilities
of Honeycomb
as we're delivering this.
It's really a stunning
experience.
Now, these are some
of the aspects
of our traditional
CNN coverage.
But in addition to that,
we have an element of the app
that we're building in
related to iReport.
And to share more
about that,
I'd like to introduce Lila.
King: Thank you, Louis.
iReport is an invitation
to anyone in the world
to participate in the news.
And today,
it's a community of about
3/4 of a million people
who share photos, and videos,
and stories of things
that are happening
in their corner
of the world.
And today, what I'm excited
to show you,
that for the first time,
iReport will be available
on a tablet.
So let's take a look
at what we have.
First, if you tap iReport
in the action bar,
what you see first
is a gallery
of the most recently featured
iReports on CNN.
They are--right now,
this is--this is live.
So what you're seeing
is Super Bowl snow helmets,
right?
Lots and lots of snow
in the Midwest.
But also, we've very recently
seen video of--
eyewitness video
of protests in Cairo,
and--and flooding
in Australia,
and what people
are actually seeing.
And all of that gets woven in
to CNN coverage
all over--all over CNN platforms
every day.
My favorite piece
of the app though
really is not just
that you can see iReports,
but you can actually
contribute one yourself.
So you could imagine
that you're standing
in the middle
of a news event
like this one, right?
And what you're seeing
in front of you
is something that you just
have to share.
You have to show
the rest of the world.
So here in the CNN iReport,
in the app for Android,
you can choose that you want
to capture a photo or a video.
Pull up your camera
that we just saw.
Line up your shot,
right?
And you could choose
to use the front-facing camera
if you'd like to describe
what you're seeing
or use the back-facing camera
to actually capture the scene.
So we've got our shot.
Thank you, Steven.
We press "OK."
Write just a little bit
about what it is
that we're seeing.
Press "Upload."
And then the story
goes right into CNN
and it gets attached
to your account on CNN iReport.
You'll also notice
that in the Honeycomb status bar
at the bottom
of the screen,
you're seeing a tiny little
iReport icon
that's indicating to you
that your story
is being posted
to iReport right now.
But if you'd like to,
you can move on
to something else.
You could close the app
and your story
will still make its way
to CNN.
So I have to say the thing
that I'm most excited about
is that when iReport
is on this tablet,
it means that it extends
the invitation to everyone
to be part of the news
to a whole new audience
of people.
And I just--I can't wait
to see what they do with it.
Gump:
So thanks so much, Lila.
Appreciate
your describing that.
What a powerful way
to connect the news
to individuals
and for certain people
who want to
to feel part of it.
If you're in Chicago
and you're in the middle
of the snow, you can still tap
into this event.
And, likewise, if we're here
in the Valley,
we can still take a look
and understand
what's going on
in the Midwest.
Now if we pan back a little bit
and look at the whole package,
what we'll have
is an application that launches
on the Xoom Tablet
in the near future.
And in addition,
will be available
on other tablets
using the Honeycomb platform
as they roll out
around the world.
And that's really exciting
to us at CNN.
I actually was just
sitting next to someone here
who said "Hey, you know,
CNN is really well-known
as a video platform--
a source of video."
And that's absolutely true.
But the combination
of the video,
and the traditional reporting,
and the imagery together,
it's just quite powerful.
And so as people use tablets
and as these grow
around the world,
we want to be there.
And people--when people
want to connect with the news,
we want to be with them
around the world.
So thanks very much
for sharing your time with us.
Barra: Thank you, Louis.
That was really amazing.
Let's just do a little bit
more multitasking here.
I'm reconnecting
'cause I'm told
our friend Lady Killer
wants to try and call in.
We'll see if that happens
in a little bit.
But, um, well,
let me just segue
to the rest
of the presentation here.
And if Lady Killer calls in,
we'll take the call.
Um, so hopefully
what you saw today
was a really good illustration
of the hard work
that we've put
into making sure
that Honeycomb is an amazing
story for developers,
which we think it is.
We think it opens
incredible opportunities
for innovation
in this new class of devices.
We certainly cannot even predict
what you,
the developer community,
are going to build.
Of course, um, the platform
is just one half of the story.
The other half of the story
is how to get these
applications--
these amazing applications
into the hands of users--
of people.
And to tell that half
of the story,
I want to invite my colleague
and friend, Chris Yerga,
who's Android's
Engineering Director
for Cloud Services.
Chris, stage is yours.
Thank you.
Yerga: Thank you very much,
Hugo.
So if Lady Killer calls in,
can I speak with him?
man: Yeah.
Yerga: Okay.
So Hugo's talking about some of
the improvement's
we're making in Honeycomb.
We're also making
some important changes
to Android Market
that I'd like to tell you about.
The changes we're making,
we're doing so
in order to meet the needs
of both users and developers.
For users, to give them
the best experience--
a variety of ways
to discover applications,
and also a very seamless path
to purchasing those applications
and installing them
on their devices.
For developers,
we want to give them
additional control over how they
promote their applications,
as well as giving them
some more flexible ways
to monetize those
applications.
I'm gonna be talking about
all of those things here today.
The first thing
that I'll be announcing
is something
I'm very excited about.
And while I'm
logging in here,
I would like to just
reiterate something
that Andy Rubin said
at the outset.
I'm actually fairly new
to Android--
fairly new to Google.
I've been here three months.
But I've been in the industry
for 20 years.
I've never worked with a team
that is as dedicated
and hard-working
as the Android team.
And the team that are
putting together
the things that
I'm showing here today
have been working tirelessly
to get them ready for you.
And so I just want to give
a bit of a shout out to them.
So the first thing
I'm happy to announce today
is the release of
the Android Market web store.
The Android Market web store
is basically the new way
that users can get applications
on their devices.
Up till now, the way
you would browse applications
and in stall them is by
using the Android Market client
on your phone.
But now,
with today's release
of the Android Market
web store,
users can go
to their browser,
discover and browse
through the entire catalog
of Android applications
on Android Market
as well as install
and purchase
directly to their device
from the web.
So let's take a look.
So as we've been building
Android Market,
we've kept in mind that
there's a variety
of different ways that users
discover applications.
Sometimes I'm coming
to the Market,
and I might not have
something very specific
that I'm looking for.
I'm more in a browsing mood,
right?
So what I want to do is
I want to come to the store
and have a variety of
different kinds of content
sort of offered up to me that
I can easily search through.
The home page of Android Market
on the web
delivers exactly that.
As you can see here
from the top,
we have a carousel
that shows a variety
of promotional banners
for applications
that cycles through.
I can click through them
and see the different apps here.
Additionally, underneath,
you'll see
the familiar categories from
Android Market on your device.
Featured Applications, as well
as Top Paid and Top Free.
And additionally,
we have categories
that can be browsed
on the left-hand side.
But I think I'm gonna
take a look here
through some of
the Featured Applications
and see if there's anything
that catches my eye.
You know, I'm sure Kenny
Chesney's a terrific singer,
but that's not really the kind
of app I'm looking for.
But hey, this Zenonia, actually,
is catching my eye.
So if I click in here,
it takes me to the applications
detail page for this app.
And so the first thing
you'll notice
is that the page is
graphically rich,
and it looks terrific.
And it looks terrific in a way
that developers can control.
In anticipation of launching
Android Market on the web,
we've enabled features
for developers
that enable them to upload
these high-resolution banners
to promote their
applications,
as well as the larger-size icons
over here on the left.
And so by doing so,
developers are able to make sure
that when people come
and look at their applications
on the Android Market
web site,
they look their best.
Additionally, you'll see here
on the left,
since this developer
has other applications
in Android Market,
they show up here,
so the folks can
easily find that.
And then all the information
a user needs
to make a decision
about whether this is
an interesting application
for them, as on the page.
We have a description,
user reviews,
as well as application screen
shots that I can look at.
And so, having looked
at this screen shot,
this actually does look like
a pretty cool app.
I think I'm gonna purchase it
and install it onto my device.
I'd like to show you
how seamless that is.
So there's a "buy" button
right here on the page.
When I click on it,
it opens up this window
that pops up, shows me
the permissions for the app,
asks me which device
I want to install to.
Since I only have one device
registered to this account,
it's pre-populated for me.
But if I had multiple devices
and tablets, et cetera,
this list would be filtered
to just those devices
that are compatible
with this application.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and purchase it.
And by clicking
on the "continue" button here,
it brings me--
Oh, I dismissed instead of
continued here.
Clicking on "continue,"
it brings up
a purchase dialogue here.
And essentially,
all I need to do
with one additional click
is complete my purchase.
However...I'm gonna put this
on the Google corporate card.
That okay, Andy?
So I complete my purchase,
and it starts charging
my credit card.
And so this is where some
of the real cloud magic happens
because as it's processing
my order,
as soon as that credit card
transaction completes,
what happens is, if we switch
over here to my phone,
you can see that I've got
a notification right up here,
and the application is
already downloading
directly to my phone.
To this works the same way
that all of our Google
Cloud-powered services work.
There's no wires, there's no
synching with computers--
none of that sort
of nonsense.
Everything is connected.
Your phone's connected
to the Cloud,
your Android Market browser
is connected to the Cloud.
And so everything
just works seamlessly
synching between the two.
And so now, just
in a few short seconds here,
I actually have the game
successfully installed
on my Nexus phone.
So that's one way
of discovering applications.
But frequently,
in addition to browsing
through a marketplace,
I often get recommendations
from my friends
about applications
I should look at.
And so the Android Market
web site
enables a lot of scenarios
around this
that are very fast
and flexible and easy.
I'd like to show
some of them to you.
So I recently had lunch
with a buddy of mine, Randy,
and he was recommending
a news reader app
that he thought
I should check out.
So he sent me this
email here.
And if I click on the link
that he grabbed
right off the Android Market
web site,
it takes me directly,
deep-linked,
to the application's
details page
for this Pulse News Reader app.
So I guess it turns out
that Randy and I have
a similar taste in apps
because this is an application
I've already installed.
And Android Market web site
knows that this is
already installed
on my device,
and tells me that here.
Another thing that is
interesting here
is that in addition
to the screen shots and banners,
this developer has uploaded
a YouTube video
to promote other application.
So we've also been
enabling features
on the Android Market
publisher site
to enable developers
to upload YouTube videos
as another way to flexibly
promote their applications,
get their message across
to users
when they're here
on the Android Market web site.
So since I have used
this application
and I really do like it,
I would like to share it
with my friends as well.
But instead of sending an email,
I think I'm gonna tweet
about it to my followers
on Twitter.
And so if you notice here
on the right-hand side,
there's a tweet button.
If I click on this, it pops up
a little dialogue from Twitter.
It's pre-populated with the link
already pre-shortened
to the application
on Android Market on the Web.
And so I can customize
the link here
and send it out
to my followers on Twitter.
And as soon as that's completed,
it'll show up on Twitter,
and anybody
who gets that message
can then click on it
and be taken directly
to the Android Market Web store.
So I can pop over
to Twitter here
and show you how this shows up
in my stream,
and there's something
kind of cool
about the way these links work,
so if I click
on the link from my computer,
no surprise,
takes me right back
to the Android Market
web site where I was.
But the other thing
I want to do
is go over here
to my phone
and show you
how the phone experience works.
These links do the appropriate
thing if you're either
on your Android device or if
you're on your browser here.
And so as we see here,
my tweet just showed up.
So I can click
on that hello one
and follow the link.
And when I do follow this link,
what happens
is that it understands
that this is a link to an
application on Android Market,
and so it takes me directly
to the Android Market client
on my phone,
which is a more convenient way
for me to install
this application
for my mobile device.
So the final way
that people get applications
is sometimes you have
a pretty good idea
of what it is exactly
you're looking for.
You might know
the specific application,
or you might have an idea
of the kind of application
you're looking for.
In this case,
my family and I
are planning
a trip to Japan.
My daughter's
already been studying Japanese,
and she's been telling me
that I have to brush up
on my katakana.
So I'm gonna search
for katakana
here on the Android Market
web site.
And when I do, I get a list
of relevant search results
from all the applications
on Android Market.
But I also have
some additional options here
about how I can present
this list.
I can elect to show
only paid or free apps
or the combination,
the both.
I can also filter by
applications that are compatible
with specific devices
that I own.
In my case,
I'm kind of curious to see
what other users
have found useful,
so I'm gonna sort
by popularity here.
And this looks interesting.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and go in here and,
since this
is a free application,
installing it on my phone
is merely a one-click process
of clicking
on the install button.
And once again it starts
"automagically" downloading
to my phone.
Having downloaded a number
of applications,
there's one final thing
I'd like to show you here,
which is
the My Market account screen.
So when I go into My Market
account, it presents a list
of all the applications
that I've previously purchased
so that I could do things,
like, click on them
and install them
to an alternate device
if I got a new phone
or a new tablet.
I can also go
into my settings page here
and give a nickname
to individual devices,
so if I have, like,
a personal phone
and a work phone,
I can keep those--
keep easier track of them
so that I know
which applications are going
to which devices.
So that's
the Android Market Web site.
It is live right now
on the Internet.
So we encourage everybody
to come to market.android.com
and see the great work
that the team has been doing.
So the next thing
I want to talk about
is related to how users
purchase applications.
So Android has a global base
of both users and developers.
But currently in Android market,
if a user is purchasing
an application in a currency
that's different
from the one the developer
is selling in,
the currency gets converted
based on an exchange rate,
and so it can be a bit
of a confusing experience
for the user.
Sometimes the prices are,
you know, funny numbers.
And developers also kind of feel
like, you know, they want
to remove
some of that confusion
as well as have
a little bit more control
over how their applications
are priced
in different currencies.
So today we're announcing
that buyer currency support
is coming to Android Market.
What this means is that,
in the developer console,
when developers upload
their applications,
for the currencies
that are supported,
they can go in and enter
explicit prices
for various currencies.
That way, it gives the user
a consistent experience,
gives the developer
a little bit more control
over how their applications
are priced
in different markets.
The way we're rolling this out
is in a phased manner.
So what's gonna happen
is today the developer console
is gonna turn on for
the initial set of currencies
for U.S. sellers.
Developers will be able
to go in there
and set those override prices
if they wish to.
If they don't,
then everything continues
working the same way
it does today.
And then over the coming months,
we'll be adding new currencies
and new seller support.
Now the final thing,
and Lady Killer
still hasn't called,
so...
The final thing I want
to show today is something
that's very exciting to us
here at Android Market.
We've gotten a fair amount
of consistent feedback
from developers
that they would like
to have additional ways
to monetize their applications
on Android Market.
So I'm very pleased
to announce that support
for In-App purchases is coming
to Android Market applications.
Now what this means
is that developers who integrate
with our In-App purchasing SDK
will be able to sell
a variety of virtual goods
directly from within
their applications.
So examples could be
a game might sell
additional levels
or consumables
or even virtual currency
that could be used in-game.
Other applications might
use this to unlock features
or premium versions
of the applications.
I mean, there's really
a wide variety of different ways
In-App purchasing could be used
by developers.
And we're very excited to see
how they use it.
We've been working
with a couple developers
initially
to get some feedback
on the In-App purchasing SDK
and also to get
some integrations going
to see how--
what they do with it.
And so I'm very happy
to invite one of them
up on stage here with me today.
I'd like you all to welcome
Bart Decrem.
He is the general manager
of Disney Mobile.
And he's got some exciting news
about their support
of Android Market
and what they've done
with the In-App purchasing SDK.
Bart?
Decrem: Thanks, Chris.
I'm Bart.
Although, I think
some of you know me better
by my nickname,
Lady Killer.
Anyway, it's really great
to be here
for the announcement today.
I think at Disney
we're a really good example
of what's going on
in mobile today.
We're bringing
some of the most beloved brands
and characters
and stories
to a new generation
of mobile devices
that are just really powerful
and fun
and just generally awesome.
And at Disney Mobile,
to date,
we've had about somewhere
over 60 million app downloads
already on other platforms,
and I think, now
that we're coming to Android,
that number's about to get
a lot bigger.
So today I'm really
excited to announce that,
for the first time ever,
we're bringing three
of our key apps
to the Android platform.
First, Radio Disney.
Radio Disney...not a lot
of kids and tweens
in the audience
here today,
but it's really
a bit of a phenomenon
with young kids
and with tweens in the U.S.,
but really
all around the world.
And with the new
Radio Disney app,
you'll be able--
the kids will be able
to stream music straight
to their Android device,
and they'll be
able to talk back.
Send out shout-outs and song
requests to Radio Disney.
The app's already been
downloaded millions of times
on other platforms, and now
we're bringing it to Android.
We're demoing it
in the other room,
and it will be launching over
the next couple of weeks.
The second app that we're
bringing to Android,
and that will be this Spring,
is "Jelly Car."
And some of you may be
familiar with "Jelly Car."
It's one of the
most popular apps
that we originally developed
for Mobile at Disney.
It's the
original physics game.
which, of course, has become
a really big category
over the last year.
And what you do is you tilt,
and you tap,
and you pinch your phone,
to navigate your car
through a set of obstacles
to the next level.
And so it really takes advantage
of all the capabilities
of these
Android devices.
That's also another
app that's been
downloaded millions
of times.
And we think we're gonna see
really big numbers on Android.
And then finally,
I'm especially delighted,
having worked on this
with the team
for three years now, to announce
that we'll be bringing
"Tap Tap Revenge"
to Android.
As you may know,
"Tap Tap Revenge"
is our most
successful franchise.
And I think it's
one of the most
popular apps ever,
on any mobile platform.
And now we're bringing it
in it's full glory to Android,
with all of the social features,
all the game play,
and then, most importantly,
all the music that is
so powerful
for our audiences.
So we've got
Lady Gaga, Katy Perry,
Linkin Park, Bruno Mars,
in the game.
And "Tap Tap Revenge"
has been downloaded
somewhere north of
50,000,000 times right now.
And we've sold more than
25,000,000 songs
in our In-App platform
across these different
versions of the game.
And because giving our users
the music that they love
and the hits that they love,
is so critical
to the user experience
in "Tap Tap Revenge,"
we've waited until
the announcement here today
of In-App billing to bring
"Tap Tap Revenge" to Android.
So let's see
what it looks like.
If we can switch
to the device.
There we go.
So here I'm running
"Tap Tap Revenge"
on a Nexus S.
But you can run it on
any YVGA Android device
that's running
Android 2.1 or higher.
And as you can see,
this is the latest version
of "Tap Tap Revenge."
It's "Tap Tap Revenge 4".
And we're showing off
some of the big hits
here on the home page.
And what I'm gonna do is
I wanna get some Bruno Mars.
So we'll tap on the icon,
and it'll take you
to our store
that's inside the app.
And then all you do is you tap
to purchase the Track Pack.
And this is the new In-App
purchasing UI from Android.
And as you see--
you see the price,
which we specify
as a developer.
And then the user has the credit
cards that they've entered,
or carrier billing that's
available for that device.
And you can just
leave that to a default,
or you can change it.
And then I'm going to
tap on the Buy button.
And here goes the In-App
purchase transaction.
And there it is.
I just purchased Bruno Mars.
And so we've preloaded it
here for the demos,
so I can simply
click here now
to go ahead and
play the song.
And the song that I'm loading
is, again, it's Bruno Mars.
He's really the biggest new
music sensation of the year.
Came out of nowhere,
has had two big hits.
This is
a new song by him.
And it's called
"Somewhere in Brooklyn."
And let's see how well I do
with the device
sort of flat on the table.
Mars: 21 years old,
I lost her in the cold.
Decrem: Bruno Mars has been
nominated for, I think,
seven Grammy Awards,
and the Grammys
are coming up
in just a week.
So you'll be hearing
a lot more of him.
Doing all right so far.
It's kind of an
easy level, actually.
I cheated a little bit
that way.
So that's "Tap Tap Revenge"
on Android.
And it's coming this Spring
with the launch of
In-App billing on Androids.
Thank You.
Yerga: Thanks a lot.
So, if I
remember correctly,
we just gave you access to
the SDK fairly recently.
Uh, how long did it take you
to get this working?
Decrem: Yeah, well,
we've had a team of developers
working on the Android version
of "Tap Tap Revenge"
for several months now.
That's been a really great
experience.
And the people we have working
on this are very talented.
But I think we got
the Code Drop,
the latest code
for In-App billing,
I think we got it
just five days ago.
So great, talented engineers,
but really,
a great code base
for the integration.
It was really easy
for us to do.
Yerga: That's terrific.
Thank you very much.
Decrem: Thank you, Chris.
Yerga: So today
we're gonna be releasing
developer documentation
for Inn-App purchasing
as well as sample code.
And, as I said, we've been
working with a few
developers to get
some early feedback on it.
Now we're going to release it
to the entire Android
Developer community,
seeking to get
some additional feedback
on the SDK,
and we're going to be
releasing it live to users
prior to the end
of this quarter.
So, uh, there's been
a lot of stuff
we've talked about today.
I think it's about time
to wrap up.
Uh, Hugo?
Barra: Yeah?
Yerga: There's some guy looking
at me from your tablet.
Barra: Oh, it's Lady Killer.
Let's switch over.
Can we get--
Can we go hot here?
Yeah?
Hey, Cee Lo.
Cee Lo: Yo.
Barra: How are you, man?
Thanks for joining us.
Cee Lo:
No problem, no problem.
Ahem.
Barra: Hey, uh, we're, uh--
We're just calling to say
that we're really looking
forward to seeing you
at the Grammys next week.
We heard you're performing
with Gwyneth and The Muppets.
That sounds pretty awesome.
Cee Lo: Yeah, it's gonna
be real cool.
Barra: That's awesome, man.
And, uh, what else
are you up to?
Cee Lo: Just that.
I'm doing a little touring
in support of the album,
which is doing very well.
Uh, you know, having
a little fun in the process,
but working very hard
at the moment.
Barra: That sounds like us
on this end, man.
We're having a ton of fun
and working very hard
at the same time.
You're probably working
harder than us, though.
Cee Lo: No, no, no,
we're neck and neck.
Hard work is hard work.
Bara: Hey, Cee Lo, all the best
next week, man.
Thanks for joining us.
Cee Lo: Thank you
for having me.
Barra: Yeah, talk to you
soon, man. Later.
Cee Lo: Peace.
Barra: Peace.
Yerga: All right,
so thanks, everyone, for coming.
I would now like to invite you
to come into the back
and look
at our demo stations,
where we have 18 developers
showing off applications
optimized for Honeycomb,
In-App billing,
and all of the new features
we've announced today.
And for those of you
who are coming
to Mobile World Congress
in Barcelona later this month,
we're gonna have
over 50 developers
showing off
Honeycomb-optimized apps there.
Developers have really been
the fuel
behind a lot
of Android's success,
and we think this year's
gonna be
bigger and better than ever
with these announcements.
Thank you very much.